so hey everybody and I personally have a
small problem with my presentation but
topic is so wide so interesting for me
so I just created about 30 slides full
of information and it's just won't be
possible to squeeze everything in so 30
minutes talk but it would be apt to
throw away information so I am just
going to keep slides of crazy but
original slides will be shared on a on a
website inside your interest so deep
reinforcement learning and it's the
least important slide but where English
is kind of interesting because of
personal reminder for me how Hardware
progressed over time for last decade
it's a real super computer system
installed twelve years ago and its total
performance was ten times less than just
video card you can buy for 700 bucks I
find it amazing so it's just real system
used for numerical computation and it
was 10 times slower than just GPU
nowadays and this is also not very
important slide I just like this dog a
lot and this meme a lot it's really cool
and the rest are just my complaining
about complexity of neural networks and
and the importance of intuition you
really need to understand what's going
on with your models or the theory behind
these models what you're expecting to
get to just make decisions about what to
what to do when your networks is not
working and how to make them work better
and in my presentation I will try to
give more about information about
intuition how to understand what's the
logic behind theory maybe with some
using not very precise mouth and
you a mathematician specializing in
reinforcement learning you may be not
really happy about my presentation so
this is a slide which shows what's a
problem we're trying to solve and why
reinforcement learning is called
enforcement learning and the basic model
is the agent is communicating with
environment somehow using some actions
and observing some state and environment
gives agent very bored and our problem
is to just how to maximize we work how
to act
using our actions and how to gather as
much water as possible and there are
examples how to formulate some
well-known situations and problems using
the enforcement learning I also skip it
and I also skip this
maybe I should know just because
enforcement learning is important
because something from my understanding
and my feeling is something in between
supervised learning when you need a lot
of label data and unsupervised learning
when you really not always know what you
end up and reinforcement learning is
something between those approaches when
you still have some driving rework value
but you don't need to label every
example and that makes it very appealing
and very general and applicable to wide
range of topics and problems and there
is a notation I used in scientific
articles and there are several
quantities which are important in fact
first is policy policy is our guideline
what we are going to do in any
particular State when we observe some
state policy gives us probability
distribution of our actions but what we
should do sometimes it can be the
domestic policy
even just set us okay do this or or
usually most of the time it's
probability distribution and ecology is
value value is just how much he worth we
go in to accumulate from this particular
state in total and Hume is also very
very important stuff and very similar to
value but it's also add action from from
which we going to accumulate and the
central star central point in
reinforcement learning is bellman
equation bellman equation has lots of
forms and lots of interpretations and
there are very wide in literature a lot
of various forms but in fact the most
for me at least understandable form of
Bowen equations here and it just says
that our value in our every state is
just local reward plus best action we
can do in terms of future reward given
by all actions we can we should and this
is my rough illustration how agents
should should should behave and Richard
bellman who was proven and wrote this
equation he just proved that if we act
according to this equation we end up
having an optimal policy and we end up
with maximum reward which is very nice
because it gives us lots the way to
solve those problems and now I'm going
to show you a bit of practice just to
fuse just to demonstrate how to what
what's possible is doable with these
methods there is nothing state of art
here it was in fact did
ah down by give mine guys four years ago
but it's a narrow Network with three
million parameters on the left's schema
mostly contained by the convolutional
networks and after about a day of
training it can learn how to play this
and you need to understand that there is
no idea about ball about this velocity
about paddle is it good or not to break
balls it just pixels observed by narrow
Network and reward value given as every
time you break the ball a break rubric
and you'll get +1 keyboard that's it and
after a day of training it can end up
playing much much better than me and
even now observing this video I just
have feeling that it in fact a person
sitting and playing the game not a
narrow network with just three million
parameters because it twice looks like
it try to push in the corner just get
more reward and their most beautiful
stuff about those algorithms that make
very general so you can take just these
methods and apply to totally different
the main maybe slightly reformulate your
inputs this will solve your problem at
least if you try to solve it
okay this is not very important why it's
about deep how-to important to go deeper
and how what quantity quantities we can
approximate with neural networks almost
any and this is also not very i've given
very important site so how to solve this
problems how to train our network to
behave optimally in terms of rewards
given by environment in fact we are two
large different approaches just
consistent direct application of bellman
equation and Vermont have programmed
that is if we act according to this
equation we will act optimally so just
act optimally we need to know Q for
every state which is can be a problem by
itself but those methods in first group
are just approximating Q in some kind
and the better approximation the better
our our own behavior
second group is not doesn't care about
reward and Q but more concerned about
policy because we at the end with you
want to act so we observe some state and
we need to choose some action and second
group called policy gradients and the
idea is to just punish actions which let
bad outcome and promote actions which
was which gave us good good reward and
those methods are policy gradient extra
critic method and executing method this
is a method which I'm going to explain
in detail later and there are some
activity
very recent last November give my guys
published a paper about the method which
tries to combine those two approaches
together and they reported that it's a
very good state of art is out on most of
Atari benchmarks which is very cool but
as far as I know there are no
open-source implementation of his
methods yet so something to be done here
ok this is not important right this is
also not very important slide because a
lot of information about key learning
and dqn algorithm because it was
historical it was first and it's a lot
of articles you can easily find them a
lot of implementation of the queuing
algorithm politic video is right also
not important because I mostly said
about it so it's we just promote action
which gave us good outcome and let's go
streak try to act a physical rhythm
which in fact act a critical not very
correct name for it because full name is
a synchronous advantage shocked a critic
and every word here has special meaning
and it can be explained but it's not
very easy so I usually call it actor
critic and as far as I know there are a
lot of people just so called code actor
critic and don't care about the
difference so they eat eight years we
will explain in details later
what is more or what is important that
this article does not give you any
reference implementation so mostly they
just give you gradients which you're
supposed to concrete turn into your code
and not they not very easy especially Q
of a forgotten calculus
so to just 25 what will be known let's
try to get understanding what they
trying to do here so let's start from
from simple thing what's happening
during plain when we are trying to
exploit our policy let's imagine we have
properly trained neural network and we
want to play the game how to do this so
at every step we observe in some some
pixels from our emulator and we see
those pixels into our network networking
access physics algorithm has to have has
two heads one head is used to
approximate polishing which gives us
probability distribution over our
actions and second head supposed to
approximate value of the state it's just
a single number showing how much rework
we are going to accumulate from this
state at least from under networks
approximation networks prediction of
volume and during plane we not care much
about value because value used only in
training as baseline we more focus more
interested about actions and actions is
a probability distribution we need to
sample to get concrete action to do and
this is very important to do sampling
and not just AG marks because one time
ago I just thought okay it's some
villages
let's drag marks it will be my action
it's totally totally wrong you need to
do random choice and that's important
because nothing will work so you sample
you get your concrete action you see
this in two environment you Atari
emulator and your environment give you
report
most of the time it will be 0 because a
word for breakout for example is 1 only
when your ball hits the bridge and this
loop is repeated 25 times per second
- just during game gameplay but if you
go into training network you need to
remember these experience with some
memory buffer as chain of actions you
did and what we worked and what
observation you experience and during
training you first of all you
calculating you discounted reward which
is just a sum with discount factor for
every state and and we start training so
as I said network has two heads justice
policy and volume and first expression
in equity gradients is just tell us how
to improve value prediction overtime the
in second just regression problem and
just mean square error this works really
nice here second part is housing of
policy and policy has exactly the same
idea we punish actions which led us to
bad outcomes and improve probability of
actions which turned out to be good all
the time and we use our discounted
reward - value predicted by network the
and this entity in this called advantage
that's why it called advantage a
synchronous activity
and the there is third component of
office function of gradient optimization
called entropy and it's infected just
some form of regularization and it is
it's used it's kind of important but
it's used more to to prevent your
network from being too deterministic so
to push it into exploration of the
states and the idea is we just trying to
maximize the entropy a bit and when
network is not really sure what actually
to do we just switch it intro into
exploration mode and according to
implementation it's possible to do to do
it two ways first of all you can
calculate the gradients by yourself
and this method is proposed by deep mind
guys in their paper and this method is
much more scalable because you don't
need to pass all pixels into central
place and do training on GPU in fact
they did all training on onions CPUs and
it worked much better than players can
converge faster but from mathematical
point of view it won't be any difference
if you just reformulate those components
and optimization variants they are loss
function and do training one central
place to be exactly the same ingredients
and this method is this way it will be
much much simpler because you don't need
to mess with manual gradients you don't
need to implement your own optimizer
because not all two kids especially here
as for example support manual tweaking
with gradients as far as I know and
that's it and you need to be aware of it
ATC method has a synchronous in its name
so one of the idea which stabilizes the
network a lot was with exploring and
getting experience not from one single
environment but from many environments
at the same time which gives much better
and develop Irian s--
and the license and speeds up wreckin
direction so implementation cop
implementation should be aware of and
support multiple agents playing at the
same time and doing optimization so yeah
and that's a training network to graph
it says exactly the same amount of
parameters as plain plain network just
extra expressions for for was was
components and extra inputs were
gathered from from experience so that's
it
this is list of things I'm measuring in
my code and so anything things are board
graphs because in fact very important to
measure and watch for various components
of your loss functions or gradients
because they shouldn't be too large or
too small and you need to understand
what the expected values and what how
they be how we should behave and how to
how the victim and this flight not
related reinforcement learning but if
you ever try to make tender board work
properly with Karis I you may notice
that its support is really really bad
and there is a solution how to do proper
monitoring of any tender in Paris and
pass it into tens abort it's a bit rocky
but it works I'm not going to explain it
details just refer to a slide it's
enough information and there is a link
to my implementation which has act a
critic extra critic without parallel
processors I don't know I call it a to
sheet but assume works if you converge
much slower but it can solve Atari games
and it has deep hue Network
implementation and I try to keep it as
clean as possible as small and
understandable so I think infected core
quad is about 300 lines something and
there is second part of my presentation
and which I'd like to to describe how to
apply reinforcement learning ideas in
more or less practical real-world
problem I'm working in company called
for Noah and our specialization is
extraction of data from websites and
analysis of it at scale and our primary
interesting Hato websites so the problem
is imaging you have hotter website and
you want to extract room prices from it
for a specific set of days like next
weekend you need to fill check-in they
check out date click a couple of links
maybe select some hotel which specific
code are you interested and then you get
list of prices with wrong rooms if
prices and you want to just extracted
that may be quite simple for human but
imagine you have hundreds of thousands
hot
with different websites or different web
design and you want to do this data
extraction on the regular regular basis
which is in fact quite hard and you want
to automate it as much as possible and
so we try to apply enforcement learning
to web page navigation and in array
enforcement learning formulation it
looks like this
so agent is browser environment is
website logic state is web page actions
are clicks for infuse all stuff user can
do in the browser and reward is the
information we are looking for so it's a
final destination either plus 1 as a
minus 1
agent need to or wants to find and I'm
going to skip this slide in fact it's
very interesting
I'm encourage you to read more about
opening a min worth of beans benchmark
but I don't have time for it and to just
start working in this direction how to
use web page navigation and how to solve
web page navigation problem using
reinforcement learning I implemented my
own small benchmark for this small set
of browser-based tasks agents supposed
to learn how to solve and it varies from
very simple just click proper link to
quite complex like feeling the selecting
proper date in a calendar toggling check
box and clicking submit and it need to
need to click a specific date on a
calendar to get positive reward and it
was network in fact it's just extra
critic network very small 990 k params
and it was a bit of tweaking about how
to see
web page elements into the network
because web page can have variable
amount of elements but it's solvable a
bit like away but it was done and I'm
not sure it's visible to everybody in
fact the most important charts are free
charts on were right the show amount
amount of reward maximum amount of a
word mean amount of remote and minimum
amount of reward gathered by agent in a
training training episode and you may
notice that even maximum amount of
rewards in the beginning of training
what training was really really
infrequent this charter training process
for the hardest problem in my benchmark
which involves calendar which you need
to select proper date longer checkbox
and click Submit but all the time it
starts to figure out how to do it more
more frequently and it starts to grow
and finally it discovered how to do it
all the time at least once because it's
maximal and at the end I think it took
about an hour to train properly it
discovered optimal polish how to click
and always get reward and our chats are
showing us various components of actor
critic like entity loss policy and body
was so of course of course just
intermediate resulted maybe even the
first step into solving it properly
because it's just a tiny benchmark but
it shows it gives some encourage how to
make how to solve this complicated
problem
in reinforcement learning waiting and we
definitely go into moving this direction
so thank you very much if you have
questions
[Applause]